s'il fallait retenir une leçon de ce
vendredi ce serait qu'un premier
ministre de droite peut en cacher un
autre
car le choix des manuels maquereau en
dit long sur la fin de son quinquennat
et l'option castex ne satisfait pas
vraiment l'opposition de gauche qu'ils
attendaient un vrai renouveau tout
change pour que rien ne change
un homme de droite remplace un homme de
droite pour mener la même politique anti
social et anti écologique
le tournant social et écologiste du
quinquennat sera donc porté par un
ancien collaborateur de nicolas sarkozy
qui petit croire avec le choix de jean
castex pour matignon la macro ni achève
son coming-out sarkozyste libé va
pouvoir recycler sa une du 16 juin
nicolas sarkozy
vraisemblablement dans l'ombre des
manuels macron estiment plusieurs
politiques en nommant jean castex
emmanuel macron fait un choix audacieux
c'est un homme que je connais et que je
respecte pour ses qualités humaines et
son expertise politique et technique
je suis cependant triste qu'ils quittent
les rangs des républicains pour
brouiller les clivages changer le
casting pour raconter toujours la même
histoire les ficelles des manuels macron
sont très usés du côté de l'ancien
président de la république parmi les
premiers informés de cette promotion
jean castex et quelqu'un pour lequel
nicolas sarkozy a beaucoup de respect
d'amitié et même d'affection assure son
entourage
ce qui n'empêche pas les tenants actuels
de la droite de ressentir cet acte comme
une trahison
à l'instar de christian jacob le chef du
parti les républicains jean castex aller
pris ses distances ces derniers jours à
partir du moment où il s'inscrit dans la
politique menée par emmanuel macron bien
évidemment il n'est plus aux
républicains en matière de trahison on a
donné déjà un nouveau visage qui du
moins dans un premier temps ne devrait
pas faire d'ombré à emmanuel macron car
la première mission de jean castex sera
le véritable casse tête que constitue la
formation d'un gouvernement et la liste
de celles et ceux qui le composeront est
attendu dans les jours à venir